systemic verbal and emotional abuse and
sexual misconduct as a result of a
culture that normalizes inappropriate
and harmful Behavior that's the damning
result of an investigation into
practices in the United States
professional women's soccer league the
scene is reeling and reactions have been
Swift the governing body U.S soccer has
promised wide-reaching changes the
owners of two clubs have removed
themselves from any decision-making
processes and one Club has fired two
Executives but that has done little to
comfort players here's U.S Defender
Becky sauerbrun
the players are not doing well we are
horrified and heartbroken and frustrated
and exhausted and really really angry
we are angry that it took a third party
investigation we are angry
that it took an article in the athletic
in the Washington Post and numerous
others were angry that it took over 200
people
sharing their trauma to get to this
point right now and I think for so long
this has always fallen on the player to
demand change and that is because the
people in authority and decision making
positions have repeatedly failed to
protect us and they have failed to hold
themselves and each other accountable
for more let's bring in two journalists
who have covered the story extensively
Meredith cash senior sports reporter for
Business Insider in New York City and
Molly catalane senior TV reporter for ad
week and host of the podcast most
powerful women in sports welcome to you
both I do want to start with you
Meredith the allegations have been
floating around for quite some time what
did this report now reveal that wasn't
already known
I think the biggest thing is the depth
of the um understanding of the abuse and
the negligence that allowed it to go on
for as long as it happened
um another big major component of this
that was unknown previously was uh the
entire situation that happened at racing
Louisville FC with head coach Christy
Hawley we knew previously that he was
terminated rather abruptly and that it
was connected to allegations of
misconduct but the story with his player
and you know for anyone who read the
investigation the opening anecdote
regarding
um an incident that happened one-on-one
with a player during a film room
um viewing
none of that was known prior to this
report so all of that was rather
staggering and I think more than
anything the depth of knowledge of all
of this was alarming for everyone one
yeah Molly the Fallout has been huge
head start rolling as soon as the report
came out but that's not going to solve
the problem is it
I wish it did but it's not it needs more
than that there was tremendous reporting
that Meg linahan and Molly Hensley
Clancy did last year that really got the
AIDS investigation started back then you
saw five of the ten coaches were out of
the league by the end of the year but
then you have a year later the Yates
report comes out and there's more we
don't even know so getting rid of a few
people in the report isn't going to
solve the problem at its core which is a
league in which misconduct has been
systemic across coaches players leagues
it it needs a complete overhaul
how can it be tackled though Meredith
where to start this is a web of abuse
condemnation complicity and fear where
do you start to overhaul that and
rebuild the structure basically from
scratch
I think the biggest issue that was laid
out pretty well in an E60 report that
aired the night after Sally yates's
report was released
um was you know the fundamental issues
at the core of this that allowed such
misconduct proliferate
um and that's the fact that there's
insecurity within uh women's
professional soccer at large and there
has been since its founding before the
national women's soccer league
um came to be in 2013 there were two
previous leagues both of which folded
after three years and so by the time you
get to the nwsl players who are there
are just feeling grateful to have a
position to play professional soccer and
so they tolerated behavior and
um
facilities and compensation that was
just substandard as a result no one
wanted to be the Whistleblower who
brought the entire league down and so
they put up with things that they
shouldn't have and so I think part of
the project that is rebuilding the nwsl
that's already underway for what it's
worth since these initial allegations
came to light late last year
um is to is to build a stronger
structurally sound League that doesn't
have these loopholes that allows players
to feel confident in speaking their
truth and and demanding what they're
worth Molly you have looked into the
response of the nwsl sponsors to the
report and they seem to be struggling to
say the least to find an appropriate way
to react don't they
struggling is to put it a little lightly
but to be fair they were probably pretty
blindsided just as a lot of us were that
hadn't seen the report and didn't fully
know the extent but my colleague Jason
Noddy and I spent pretty much 48 hours
straight after the report came out
reaching out to sponsors across the
league
um and specific teams as well
specifically teams like the red stars
the Portland Thorns racing Louisville
teams that were really named in the
report so we reached out to 19 we heard
back from ten since then a couple more
have released statements but it's been a
lot of corporate jargon a lot of deeply
Disturbed which I'm sure they are as we
all are
but I think what a lot of these Brands
and sponsors either don't want to
realize or just haven't realized is the
power a lot of the power lies within
them too it's been a lot of we can't we
need to see what the nwsl does we're
hoping for change so we all are but if
these Brands want to continue sponsoring
the nwsl and I hope they do because I
don't want the league to fold nobody
wants the league to fold and you need
sponsors they need to use their power as
sponsors and their spending power to try
and force the nwsl end to change and for
what it's worth I really do believe US
soccer and the nwsl are committed to
meaningful change and have already
started making those steps but one
sponsored reaction that really did stand
out to me was Ally Financial
they're a nationwide sponsor they're the
lead kit sponsor or sleeve sponsor so
their CMO Andrea Brimmer is calling for
Meaningful change to find the truth no
matter how painful and I'd like to see
more Brands react like that
how have the teams reacted because this
investigation was focused on three teams
in particular Meredith did one of these
teams stick out with a particularly a
good response in your view
honestly no I wouldn't say that any one
team's response has been
um particularly impressive the Portland
Thorns did part ways with two Executives
who were known for a while now to have
been aware of the abuse and have
essentially turned a blind eye and given
a vote of confidence to Paul Reilly as
he went from the Portland Thorns to the
North Carolina courage another team in
the league
um
but you know the Portland Thorns owner
Merritt Paulson was also aware of these
allegations also voiced confidence and
support for
Paul Riley
as he moved on to another team within
the league knowing what he had done
within their own franchise
um and you know as long as he is the
person who has the most power in that
franchise I don't think that's good
enough personally and I think a lot of
fans and a lot of players have voiced
the same opinion Becky sauerbrun the
player you just uh played a sound bite
from voice the same thing during her
recent um her recent interviews and I
think that's true across the board right
I think in Louisville with Christy Holly
and with Rory Dames in Chicago with the
red stars there were people in positions
of power who knew and are still in
positions of power within those
franchises and none of the three have
gone as far as to weed out every single
person who knew and until that happens I
don't think players will be satisfied
nor will fans a lot of work ahead for
the nwsl Meredith cash Business Insider
and Molly Callahan of AD week thank you
so much for your time